i remember when  you're going into the hall of fame phil  jackson penned a letter to you  and in that letter he's talking about  how he would ask his player sometimes to  do book reports  and at one point he gave you the book  said hartha  and you actually did the book report  and he said that the first line of your  book report said  siddhartha is a book about a young  prince who has money fame and women just  like me  he is also searching for self-discovery  just like i am  when you wrote that what point in your  self-discovery journey  were you at  i realized that phil jackson  because he's a scholar he would look at  certain people and be like okay he's  this and he would give you these books  and you read and you read those journeys  i was like oh okay but what phil doesn't  understand is cliffnotes.com  had just opened up at that time i didn't  read that book i'm not reading no down  but i got a season to play  clifflopes.com on that last